it's great to be joined today by David
Weintraub who is professor of astronomy
at Vanderbilt University also author of
the just-released book life on Mars what
to know before we go I've been following
Mars for a long time not literally in
orbit but the attempts to get humans to
Mars possibly do some missions to Mars
and and everything that's being
discussed by both government and private
industry around the world and I'm
curious what you see as sort of the
reason to go to Mars if there is one
overarching reason is it the possibility
of life there is that what we might
learn about subsequent space travel
technology what would you sort of assess
as the real attraction of going to Mars
I think that actually depends on who
you're talking to if you're talking to a
planetary astronomer I think the
attraction is to discover whether
there's life on Mars already whether
Martians already are there if you're
talking to most people who are
supporting the space program I think
people want to colonize Mars I think
people see Mars as it's there we should
do it sort of like climbing Mount
Everest why do you do it because you can
we have the technology or very close to
having the technology to be able to get
humans to Mars so why not go I think
it's just because it's there and we can
do it is the academic community worried
about how there seems to be increasingly
a sort of manifest destiny type interest
in Mars and business interests like is
that of concern within the academic
community outside of my office I'm not
convinced it is yet huh of concern to me
I represent one person in the academic
community I don't know if there is a a
building sentiment within the planetary
astronomy community that thinks the same
as me I'm trying to advance that idea
publicly to get people talking about it
to me the possibility that life does
exist on
Mars and I think a number of people who
think that possibility is real that
possibility to be makes the idea of
colonizing Mars problematic interesting
and you say that because of the
possibility of disrupting the life that
may be there that's right we of course
know nothing about the life that's there
because we don't know whether there is
life in but if there is life there I
think it would be naive of us to think
that we would not affect that life in
some way probably in a negative way it's
also possible that life on Mars would
not be healthy for us that the
contamination could go both ways but
what I'm more concerned about is the
possibility that we could destroy life
on Mars by contaminating Mars that life
on Mars if it exists has evolved to be
healthy in the Martian environment and
that Martian environment does not
include human DNA or terrestrial
bacteria and if we introduce those to
Mars that could be very damaging to the
Mars and ecosystem and right now just to
clarify for the audience when when you
say there's a possibility that there's
life on Mars we're talking about
microscopic life right like the idea
that we might show up and there were
just elephant sized beings that we
missed nobody is holding out for that
we're talking about my microscopic life
that's absolutely correct
Carl Sagan was fond of talking about
what he called back robes as opposed to
microbes and the camera is on the Viking
landers in 1976 provided pretty
definitive proof that there were no
macros on Mars and we have great maps of
the entire surface of Mars now with our
orbiters with our Landers we know
there's no large-scale life wandering
around on the surface but microscopic
life could exist almost certainly if it
does exist in existence below the
surface not on the surface because the
Martian surface is a pretty hostile
environment so of all the different
plans that are out there to go to Mars
there's the Mars one project you've got
Elon Musk and SpaceX working on a
proposal we don't have to sort of
list all of the different ones at the
top level what is the biggest area of
concern in terms of how it is being
conceived is it that the radiation
during the trip affecting humans hasn't
been properly considered in terms of how
to mitigate is it something about the
realistic or lack of realism and
thinking about how we will have our own
food when we get there what what top
level concern is there that's like the
missing piece from the plans that are
out there I think the things you
mentioned are problems that everybody is
aware of the harsh radiation environment
for astronauts getting to Mars and
surviving on Mars everybody involved in
these projects knows that that's a
formidable obstacle we have not yet
solved that problem of how to protect
astronauts on Mars from cosmic rays from
solar flares that's a big problem but
it's not one that people are unaware how
to find food for people living on Mars
people are aware of that problem I don't
think the problems been solved but
people are working on it providing
habitat habitats for people who live on
the surface of Mars people are working
on that but the problem is not so how to
get people home from Mars I think that's
a problem that I imagine the
entrepreneur is trying to get us to Mars
are aware of but I don't think there is
concerned about that as I am I think we
have the ability or will soon have the
ability to get astronauts to Mars if we
land them on the surface we do not have
the ability and are nowhere close to
having the ability of lifting them off
the surface and bringing them home now
some projects that's not a problem right
I mean there are projects that are
saying we're thinking of these as
one-way missions that's right they're
thinking of these as one-way missions
because that's the only way they can
conceptualize these missions since they
can't bring these astronauts or colonies
home
I think that's ethically wrong I don't
think we have the right to send people
to Mars if we don't have the ability to
bring them back home well I mean right
is an interesting term right it this
would depend on what they are agreeing
to conceive
if you volunteer on the basis that you
know you're not coming back who is it
that is misguided they're right I mean
it's at a certain point if people are
determined to say I want to go and I
don't care if I can't come back whose
responsibility is it to say hey maybe
that's a little crazy it served me a
little crazy certainly a great deal of
the responsibility is on the individual
who might choose to volunteer to go on a
one-way mission but I think we need to
be clear because of the problems we've
identified the fact that we can't
protect people right now from the harsh
radiation environment because we don't
know how we're going to feed people by
growing food on Mars for the long term
we don't know if we can supply them
regularly enough to keep them alive
we're effectively sending people on a
suicide mission not on a mission to be
permanent colonists on Mars where they
have a robust chance to actually survive
or much of their foreseeable lifetime if
they stayed on earth they are taking on
huge risks and again as you know they be
volunteers at the moment they would have
to be volunteers but do they really
understand the risks they're taking the
possibility that their time as a
colonists on Mars might be very very
short of all the different timelines
that have been presented right SpaceX
wants to go in the early 2020s Mars one
is talking about early 2030s everybody
has their different timelines if you
just sort of give your overall
impression what do you think is a
realistic timeline for the first human
on Mars
I think Elon Musk has met every that
deadline he set for himself so I fully
expect that his bfr rocket will be ready
to go in a couple of years and that it
will be capable of taking humans to Mars
by 2024 which is what he plans on I
think he is very likely to be able to
get humans to Mars by the mid 20 21 you
think about the problem that you point
out that right now
someone going on a one-way mission
whether it is in 2024 whenever it is it
is a sort of suicide mission although
certainly any one way many one way trip
anywhere is sort of a suicide mission
and that if you don't come back from
that place you will eventually die there
right but but understanding sort of the
scope of an urgency of what you're
saying what would be the way that it
could be done such that that's not the
case for the first people to go is it
sending supply craft ahead of time as
well as robotic machinery that can start
to develop the environment where humans
would eventually live upon arrival like
how do you fix that issue those are good
questions
I would imagine again those involved are
thinking hard about this
we can send unmanned delivery capsules
send hundreds of them for example with
food with supplies with shelters if in
fact we can build the shelters that
would work we can continue to send
unmanned supply ships to continue to
keep them well supplied if we have the
financial wherewithal to do that each of
these missions is very expensive I
haven't tried to price out how often we
need to send a resupply miss and to keep
a handful of colonists alive but I think
the price is astronomical this is what
we're dealing with but I think we in
principle we could send lots of supply
ships ahead of time lots of machinery
ahead of time if we think the people
need to live underground rather than on
the surface we could send some kind of
drilling machinery ahead of time that
robotic Li could carve out a cave in
which they could live all of that could
be done long before the actual humans go
but not if we're trying to go in 24 24
if we're trying to go in 2024 most of
those supplies most of those machines
will not have been built or developed in
let alone sent to Mars
the book is life on Mars what to know
before we go we've been speaking with
the books us author professor of
astronomy at Vanderbilt University David
Weintraub David thank you so much for
talking to us
today where's your join you